so next game kolum from
USA so I'm trying to create a Slavic exchange again
okay he does
n't want to go well then let's play
a very long slow
Kolle
not much going on in the
position so
try to put the knight in a bad position I
had you too  F calculated
somehow h
yes yes everything seems very solid for
Black
no I don't know exactly count on being
able to do something great here
like E5 and then knight
E4 maybe I can also do D5
D5 well but that won't be really correct either
na  yes but it's not
uninteresting let's try if
now ed ed yes we ca
n't get through anything at all whether he
can take it somehow or
something so my idea was
actually to
play like that now maybe you
still have a few chances  the
bishop on B2 has now just
become strong so on knight D5 I now thought of
queen
D4
with the idea of ​​playing on bishop F8 then knight
D6
but of course he can, you have to
admit, just withdraw knight F6 now
and then I
actually can't do anything particularly great  Yes,
I should probably take the 6 too,
well, but you definitely kept a bit of
activity.
The bishop is
definitely much stronger than the knight on
A6 Check and it still has a bit of
weak back row. Well, it actually looks good,
no  Bishop F6 now
also threatens to play D8
red
not exactly
subtly so maybe now to play knight D4
and then knight F5
yes you now have a really better
move than knight
B5 me that's not bad now
or can you I would like to
continue attacking
Somehow you can see the position but I can't see
it, but it's definitely not a
bad
move,
so now if he takes it on
e5 Bishop
E5 then A7 is really difficult to
defend, yes the knights are
kind of pretty
sad like that  That's why
the fields here are always
nicely controlled t
very unpleasant position no
what should black
play so now take it or do I have
a better
move yes at least now I ca
n't see it being so easy to go back
and now he's still in such a strange position with the
knights
So he can't actually do much,
no, so you can make a few more reinforcements here,
yes, I should have
looked again,
or a bit stupid, no,
I would definitely have something
stronger to go with it, well, that's the
idea now, tower
E7, well  yes, it's still
strange,
but still, maybe g is
a bit
stronger,
so I'm a LAH
duck.
Check and I didn't play it really well either. Of
course, it's still
good somehow, but well, maybe I've got
B7 now with tur  Progress
made
Check yes, of course that's
nice, it shortened it a lot,
especially with the 30 seconds on the
clock